Nearly 3,000 people were killed on September 11th, 2001 when al-Qaeda hijackers...
...crashed commercial planes into the World Trade Center,...
...the Pentagon and the field in Pennsylvania.
Among those killed was 26 - year - old James Cartier.
He was working as an electrician on the 105th floor of the south tower...
...when the plane slammed into the buildings.
After his death, James's brother John launched American Brotherhood MC,...
...a motorcycle club honoring one of James's favorite hobbies.
I view this whole event different than most.
I'm a survivor from the collapse.
I was standing right in front of Century 21...
...when the south tower came down on the middle of the street, holding my sister's hand.
At the same time that me and my sister were running, my brother was losing his life.
I returned to Ground Zero in the hopes to find my brother...
...and stayed on there, on and off for seven and a half months in the recovery effort.
Cartier says the motorcycle club helps keep the memory of his brother alive.
What's important to me today, tomorrow, yesterday...
...is the fact that my brother James was a beautiful human being.
He was loving, he was caring, he was courteous, he was always a gentleman...
...and his voice was silenced.
So, I go forward every day and I feel good when I talk about him...
...because it lets me tell the world who he was.
Peter Marino's father, Lester, was also killed that day.
It's definitely very emotional; it is very sad.
It's very tough to get through.
Of course, there's a lot of anger too but...
...you try to be there for each other more than anything.
It's great that everybody comes together and is there for each other, you know...
...'cause everybody understands.
Each year the family members of those killed on September 11th....
...gather at the World Trade Center site for a memorial ceremony.